Yeah, it is.
Got it.
[Music]
She
actually
[Music]
Remember?
[Applause]
Yeah. There was a
[Music]
Wow. Nice.
That's where
[Music]
Sorry, brother.
[Applause]
[Music]
dinner. Nice to meet
you.
[Music]
How's everybody?
Really bad.
[Music]
[Laughter]
Okay.
[Music]
upgraded
vegetarian teacher.
Hi. Uh, my name is Rachel. I use she her
pronouns. I'm so excited you're here
with us today. Got a couple of
announcements for you. Um, first is
during our Easter service on Saturday
the 19th, we're having an Easter egg
hunt for the kiddos. Um, uh, so if you
could please bring as many free stuffed
Easter eggs as you're willing to make to
the church one week from today. If you
already have some, there's a blue bucket
right out there that you can put those
[Music]
into here.
Exciting.
Um we'll have an area right up there. Um
again that's one week from today that we
are collecting those. Next Sunday, April
13th is Palm Sunday. Um which kicks off
Holy Week. We'd love for you to
participate in the waving of Palms with
us. Uh so we'll line up a few minutes
before 5 um in the hallway or in the
lobby. Um on Good Friday, we're
attending Saxi First service at 700 p.m.
on April 18th. And our Easter service
will be
this to see
there. Um and then also Saturday the
third 12th or 13th the relationship
class 13th. Okay. Yes. one for today uh
Sunday. Uh there is a relationship class
and you can um scan the QR code and sign
up for
that. Um next is our accessibility
bucket. So that's that black bucket
right over there. Um if you're anxious
about being in a church setting, you're
dealing with issues today, you're part
of the disability community, we have
some tools and fidgets available to you
to use to hopefully ease any anxiety.
There are
always
pages. We enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness, and simplicity. A sacred
space, a place for prayer, worship and
adoration, a place to behold Christ,
revelation of God and heartbeat of
creation. Allow the unforced rhythms of
grace to find you, to mend your heart.
May we all come
home. Thank you, Rachel. If you guys
want to stand with us, we're going to
get started with our worship tonight.
And I wanted to read from Psalm
34. It says, "I will extol the Lord at
all times. His praise will always be on
my lips. My soul will boast in the Lord.
Let the afflicted hear and rejoice.
Glorify him with me. Let us exalt his
name together. I sought the Lord and he
answered me. He delivered me from all my
fears. Those who look to him are
radiant. Their faces are never covered
with shame. Taste and see that the Lord
is good. Blessed is the one who takes
refuge in
him. Through every
battle, through every
heartbreak, through every
circumstance, I believe that you are my
fortress. You are my
portion. You are my hiding place.
I believe you are the
way and the
[Music]
truth, the
life. I believe you are the
way and the
truth, the
life. I believe you are.
I
believe you
are through every
promise, through every
promise, through every breath I
take. I believe that you are
provider and you are
protector and you are the one I love.
I believe you are the
way and the
truth, the
life. I believe you are the
way and the
truth and the
life. I believe you are.
[Music]
Yeah,
we
[Music]
believe it's a new
horizon and I'm set on
you. And you meet me here today with
mercies that are
new. All my fears and
doubts, they can all come true because
they can't stay long when I'm here with
you.
It's a new
horizon and I'm set on
you. You meet me here today. Mercies
that are
new and all my fears and
doubts, they can all come to because
they can't stay long. And I believe you
are the
way and the truth and the
life. I believe you are the
way and the
truth, the life.
I believe you are the
way and the
truth and the
life. I believe you are the
way and the
truth, the
life. I believe you are.
[Music]
cuz it's a new
horizon and I'm set on
you. You meet me here today with mercies
that are new.
All my fears and
doubts, they can all come too because
they can't stay long when I'm here with
you. All right, kiddos. You guys are
dismissed to go to your
classes. Thank you so much, Meyn and
Chrissy and Jill and Joe,
Max. We appreciate all of you guys for
loving on them, showing them the love of
God each
[Music]
week. And as they transition out of the
room, we are going to move into the
prayers of the people. So, if you guys
would follow along and read the parts in
red together on the screens and then
lift up whatever you might be carrying
into this space aloud when we come to
that part of the
[Music]
prayer. Jesus, for this city of Saxi,
Texas, and for every city and community
and all who live in them, we pray to you
for the good earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it.
We pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
[Music]
Johnny Owen,
Debbie,
teachers, for the names and the moments
that we have spoken aloud. God. And for
those that we have kept in our hearts,
we pray to you that they may have life
and light, healing and hope, peace and a
deep sense of your presence. Amen.
[Music]
I want to know you,
Lord, like I know a
friend. I want to know you, Lord.
[Music]
I want to know you,
Lord, like I know a
friend. Want to know you,
Lord. So, I'm laying
down all my
religion. I'm laying
down. I want to know you, Lord.
I'm laying
down all my
religion. I'm laying
down. I want to know you,
Lord. I want to know you, Lord.
[Music]
I used to
think that I could box you
in, but I'm laying
down. I want to know you,
Lord. I used to
think I could box you
in, but I'm laying
down. Want to know you, Lord.
Want to know you,
[Music]
Lord. Lord, I've been
told to be
ashamed. Lord, I've been
told I don't measure
up. Lord, I've been
told I'm not good enough.
You're here with me.
[Music]
I reach out and
you find me in the dust.
Say no amount of
untruth can
separate us.
[Music]
I reach out and
you find me in the dust.
Say no amount of
untruth can
separate us.
[Music]
I reach out and
you find me in the dust.
You say no amount of
untruth can
separate us.
Oh,
I will rejoice
in the simple gospel.
in you, Lord.
I will rejoice
in the simple
gospel. I will rejoice
in you, Lord.
[Music]
I will rejoice.
I will rejoice
[Music]
in you, Lord.
I will rejoice
I
will in you.
[Music]
I will
rejoice in you.
rejoice in the simple
gospel. I will
rejoice in you, Lord.
[Music]
Come to the
water all who are
thirsty. Come and
[Music]
drink. Come to the
table. All who are hungry.
[Music]
and
fear. Those who are
weary, those who are
needy, come
receive. Come to the
river. Come to the
river. Taste the sea.
[Music]
Taste and
see. Come to the
water. All who are
thirsty, come and drink.
Come to the
table all who are
hungry. Come and
[Music]
feed those who are
weary, those who are
needy. Come
receive. Come to the river.
Come to the
river. Taste and
[Music]
see.
Oh, oh my soul, it thirsts for you and
you alone.
[Music]
Oh my soul, it thirsts for you and
your
[Music]
oh my soul, it thirsts for you and you
alone.
[Music]
Oh my soul, it thirsts for you and you
are
all. I will taste and see that you are
good. I will taste and see that you are
good.
I will taste and see that you are
good. You're good to
[Music]
me. I will taste and see that you are
good. I will taste and see that you are
good.
I will taste and see that you are good.
You're good to
me.
Oh, oh my soul, it thirsts for you and
you alone.
[Music]
Oh my soul, it thirsts for you and you
alone.
[Music]
Oh my soul, it thirsts for you and you
are.
[Music]
alone. Come to the
water all who are
thirsty. Come and drink.
Come to the
table all who are
[Music]
hungry. Come and
feed. I will rejoice
in the simple
gospel. I will
rejoice in you, Lord.
I will rejoice
in the simple gospel.
in you,
Lord. I will rejoice
in the simple gospel.
I will rejoice
in you, Lord.
I will
rejoice in the simple
gospel. I will rejoice
in you,
Lord. In you, Lord.
God, tonight as we gather
together, we remember that you are a God
who
protects, who
provides. You are the lifter of our
heads. And those who look to you are
radiant. Their faces are never covered
with shame.
God, would we let go of
shame? Would we let go of
fear? Would we let go of the voices who
said we weren't good
[Music]
enough? And would we remember that you
made us and you formed us in our
mother's womb.
You saw
us and you said it is
good. They are
good. He is good. She is
good. God, would we hear the voice of
you? A loving God, a loving
creator. Would it ring louder than any
voice in our
head? Would it steady us when we are
scared? Would it hold us when the world
around us is falling apart?
[Music]
And would we offer that hope to the
world around
us? That same security, that same
identity, that same promise of a good
God who loves his
creation, who is with
[Music]
us in Jesus
name.
[Music]
Amen. Thank you guys so much for
worshiping together with us. if y'all
would say hello to the people around you
and then Brett will get us started on
the
[Music]
message. Well, grace and
peace. So good to be with you all. So so
good. My name is Brett and uh the pastor
here and yeah, it's just a joy joy to be
with you um to welcome you into this
space and as always that includes those
joining us online. Y'all are not
forgotten. Thanks for being with us
through the wonders of the internet and
uh anyone here tonight who is uh new,
maybe it's your first time or just your
first time in a long time. Um we're
really really glad you're here. I know
it can just be a lot coming through
those double doors and uh especially
depending on like church background and
history and uh it's like it can just be
a lot. So um yeah, so we don't take it
for granted and we're really really
grateful um that you're here among us.
So um we are currently um we kind of
follow the the general Christian
calendar most of the time. So we're in
the season right now that's called Lent.
And uh this is a a 40-day time of kind
of heart and mind preparation as we uh
you know are approaching Easter. So um
I've I've enjoyed like in my younger
years as a child I didn't go to a church
that followed the church calendar and I
noticed that sometimes Easter snuck up
on me and I was kind of like oh wow
Easter okay all right well hooray he's
resent you know I didn't really feel
like I went through the process kind of
prepare and you know like the whole um
kind of thing. So, uh, as Rachel
mentioned earlier, we do have, um, Holy
Week, uh, coming up and, uh, actually, I
guess kicking off with Palm Sunday next
week. So, um, I encourage you to for
that that kind of week especially to be
really, um, tuned in, um, and, uh, not
only, you know, as you're able to attend
things here, but even just, you know,
spend some time with God uh, alone. And
I know, you know, we get busy and such,
but, um, really carve that out and and
prioritize. There's something so
refreshing and life-giving. Um and it
just becomes so much more meaningful,
you know, the celebration of Easter and
such when we've taken some of that time.
So um the the title of my message this
week is perceive it. Perceive it or
another word that's sort of fancy word
for see it. And uh our Old Testament
reading is from uh the book of Isaiah
chapter 43 16- 21. Um you'll notice it's
a very um kind of beautiful very poetic
uh passage and uh Isaiah he writes these
words. He said this is what the Lord
says. He who made a way through the sea
a path through the mighty waters who
drew out the chariots and the horses,
the army and reinforcements together and
they lay there never to rise again
extinguished snuffed out like a wick.
Forget the former things. Do not dwell
on the past. See, I'm doing a new thing
now. It springs up. Do you not perceive
it? I'm making a way in the wilderness
and streams in the
wasteland. The wild animals, they honor
me. the jackals and the owls. Because I
provide water in the wilderness and
streams in the wasteland to give drink
to my people, my chosen, the people I
formed for myself that they may proclaim
my
praise. You can kind of hear the poetry,
the some of the beauty in that. So, this
is a it's a it's a very powerful passage
and it's it's one you can see why uh
kind of throughout church history
they've chosen to include this in the
season of Lent since it's very um it's I
don't know it's it's very uh well it
just aligns well with the season right
because it's it's kind of naming how
metaphorically
um speaking right your your journey on
the path of Christ begins uh much like
Christ himself self with um the
basically the moment you start to leave
the city so to speak like in essence you
all of us right not just the the
children of Israel or something you know
thousands of years ago but all of us we
too have to leave
Egypt leave the city leave what the
world would call kind of the the so-cal
like you know the so-called good life um
really starting to realize it um not for
the awesomeness that it is and wanting
to reject awesome things but realizing
it for the poverty of what it is. So we
might call this u kind of phase one of
our spiritual journey. We call phase one
um leaving Egypt. And you can see this
kind of hinted at in this passage in
verse 16. It says this is what the Lord
says. He who made a way through the sea,
a path through the mighty waters, who
drew out the chariots and horses, the
army, the reinforcements together, and
they lay there never to rise again,
extinguished, snuffed out like a wick.
So, if uh you're familiar with the book
of Exodus in scripture or a little bit
into numbers, um or if you've just seen
the movie The Ten Commandments, um you
know, you're kind of familiar with this
this scene, right? Let my people go. And
it's, you know, that whole kind of
moment of leading the people, the God's
people out of where? Out of Egypt,
right? Out of the city, uh, through the
Red Sea. And, uh, this
becomes sort of a, uh, a picture, right?
This this moment um, where Isaiah is
writing, hey,
remember back how God not literally,
because he's not writing to people who
literally experienced that. sort of in
the same way like we weren't there, you
know, but but at another level, Isaiah
is saying, well, you were right. You're
part of this tradition, this people who
God keeps calling out of
uh places of pain and
oppression. So, there's this uh this hit
kind of HBO series, which I everyone was
talking about. I'm like way behind. Uh
so, I decided to give it a watch. I just
watched the first season. um White
Lotus, old
HBO and uh to be clear, I'm not like
recommending the show. I mean, it's
quite runchy and such, you know, so it's
like, oh, Pastor Brett said everyone
must at this church must watch White
just saying that. But um it I mean it
was powerfully written and uh for those
who haven't seen it. So, it revolves
around this sort of uh it's like there's
an almost entirely new cast of
characters apparently each season with
maybe a little little carryover and the
the setting is this luxury, you know,
resort um of course named White Lotus
and uh it's so it's kind of just
following the stories of the people
there and um the thing is like I mean of
course the setting right it's totally
beautiful uh the just everything, the
architecture, the views, the food, the
wine, the massages, the pampering, the
conversations people are having, you
know, it's just sort of all very like
upper class and it's, you know, it's
just everything's sort of uh at least on
the surface kind of uh exquisite, you
know. But of course, then there's like
behind the scenes of Paradise, you have
like the workingclass folks who are
actually making that place happen,
right? And so they're they're kind of uh
the servers and and folks. And so
they're kind of begrudgingly like
serving the upper classes while also
kind of secretly like envying them and
kind of longing to be them but also uh
quite angry at them. You know, there's
like a lot there's lots of feelings
going on. Um, and of course like the
people, if you just look at the
characters, this is where I will say
this show is a little bit hard to watch
because there's not necessarily anyone
to root for, if you know what I mean.
It's just not one of those kind of
shows. It's sort of like gosh, is
everyone just crappy? you know, but I
think in that way it sort of it very
much mirrors a lot of modern life, you
know, because I mean the truth is we're
all kind of like struggling, you know,
like there there's these sort of aspects
of us that are like incredible and
awesome and you know, but if there was a
show made about the shadow sides of each
and every one of us, well, that'd be
White Lotus, right? In essence, it's
just kind of like, oh wow, who are these
people? You know, it's like it's really
uh intense and uh slightly awful. And um
of course and I'm not even saying that
just about the rich patrons of the
resort like even the the service workers
like they're in their own messes and you
know struggling and dysfunctioning all
over the place, you know. So um what's
interesting is even though like
geographically they're in
paradise, it's perfect. It's
beautiful. They're not. I mean they are
but they aren't like they're in the hell
of Egypt. That's where they are, right?
The the Egypt
representing greed representing trauma,
injustice, oppression, depression,
alcoholism, workcoholism, racism, drug
addiction, screen addiction, every other
trap humans fall into. There's even a a
great moment where one of the
characters, he's like trying desperately
kind of to break away. He kind of
realizes like the craziness of this life
and he's just like he's at one point he
says, "I want to live. to live. Like
he's he's trying he can kind of sense
like I'm here in the so-called good
life, but it's not. I'm in hell. I'm I'm
in the hell of
Egypt. Like in essence, this resort,
White Lotus, right? It's it's our
society. It's this kind of
carnival of distraction meant to keep
you both productive and kind of
endlessly chasing pleasure.
So that in the Bible that's represented
by Egypt. Uh later in scripture it will
be replaced with Babylon, right? In the
book of Revelation it's like Babylon,
Babylon, Babylon, this and that, right?
So that's sort of later becomes Babylon,
but early in scripture it's um
represented by Egypt. So, in essence,
um, if you kind of can see what Isaiah
is getting at, what he's naming is that
God is the one who calls all of us out
of
Egypt. In other words, out of the
carnival of oppression and depression,
injustice, trauma, and
greed. This is our
journey now.
What we would like to think, and I'm
right with you on this, is we would like
a like we like to go directly from Egypt
to the promised land, so to speak,
right? To the Holy Land. Like we want a
first class ticket, a one-way flight to
oneness with God. you know, like all the
things we sing about just your presence,
the Lord, and the love of God and the
joy of God and the peace that passes all
understanding, you know, it's like all
that we're like, "Yes, I want that." You
know, but uh the truth is that's not
quite um how it works, right? Because
the problem is we've spent our whole
life in Egypt and we don't realize the
degree to which it's got its hooks into
us and it's not so easily
extracted right because again Egypt
understood spiritually not so much a
geographic place but it's this internal
state of addiction and attachment and
affliction and all that right which then
of course manifests outwardly socially.
um not trying to deny kind of social
systems and structures and you know
problems there but it it flows right
from the the heart of human beings that
it and kind of our imaginations and our
own uh being and it comes out and
manifests externally in the world in all
sorts of crazy terrible awful ways right
so um in essence maybe one way to think
of this is if you were like take someone
like a friend like to rehab you like you
need to go to rehab and they're like
okay I know I know it's my time they go
they check in 24 hours later they call
you they're like okay I'm
good, right? You'd probably be a little
like, "Oh, I don't know. I don't know. I
don't think so. I don't that's not quite
how it," you know, just a quick little
turnar around there. Like, we know this
is a this is a process. You think a few
weeks, 30 days, 60 days, you know, like
this is this is a process. And it's
similar um with with Egypt. So, that
leads us to phase two, right? We go from
leaving Egypt phase one into phase two,
entering the desert. Doesn't that sound
like fun? Woo! They're like, "This
sermon, this is a joy."
Um, entering the desert, also known as
the wilderness. Oh, that's the language
Isaiah kind of prefers here. I kind of
like that, too. It's a little poetic.
The wilderness. Yeah. Um, now the desert
is this key time of, uh, formation,
um, a kind of, uh, puration, a kind of
cleansing out, you know, that can last
years, decades in the in the Christian
life. So, the Israelites go to the
desert. uh many of the prophets
throughout all the scriptures the desert
you think of like John the Baptist uh
the famous forerunner of Christ you know
lived in the desert Jesus famously
spends 40 days and 40 nights there
fasting right in the desert before he
kicks off his ministry so you know so
what's the dev the desert in this kind
of way I'm I'm talking tonight it's uh
well it's rehab right it's this um it's
this place of of healing um it's hard
right but no one would say like rehab's
bad. It's like is the desert bad? It's
like well it depends on your
perspective, right? It's sort of hard
sometimes hard as hell, you know, like
oh that was a but a lot of but folks who
go through rehab know like hardest thing
I ever did, best thing I ever did.
That's sort of the desert. Hardest thing
I ever went through, best thing I ever
went through. Like this was powerful in
my life because it got me from where I
was enslaved in Egypt and it got me to
freedom. Right? So it's good but
difficult to kind of paraphrase the
Christian artist and writer Jonathan
Pacio. He says, "The desert is where all
that is unfit within us. For the holy
land is burned away." I like that. All
that's unfit within us burned away. Now,
I should name by the holy land, the
promised land here. I'm not thinking
necessarily of like heaven, heaven after
you die. So, you know, you just live
this life and it's the desert and then
you'll die and then you'll go to heaven,
you know. Uh, I mean, I think that could
be kind of part of it, but um, I'm
thinking a more like what I mentioned
earlier, you know, the the things we
sing about, the the love of God, the
presence of God, the the the joy that
that, um, if the if generations who have
come before us are to be trusted, and I
think they are, then they've named that
uh, an increasing freedom does happen,
an increasing peace can happen, that we
really can't have the mind of Christ as
Paul says like that's not just sort of
spiritual flowery language that means
nothing like no it's an actual lived
experience a kind of embodied
knowingness of like what it's like when
God in Christ sort of uh gets a hold or
or um comes into contact with a human
being. Um, so that's that's more what
I'm thinking. I'm saying holy land,
promised land. It's, you know, I'm not
necessarily thinking just like heaven
when you die, you know, but I'm thinking
something um more so in essence, you
might say the desert is this kind of
stripping away of all that covers over
or kind of blinds us to our shared
nature with God in Christ. Uh kind of an
example of of where this can go a little
bit wrong though, I um something this
really caught me off guard in my kind of
decade or so of pastoring. Um it's
around baptism. So I've noticed this
kind of trend. So we've had more than
one people like a number of folks who uh
will kind of like be quite involved in
the table for you know some period of
time like usually years. Um and then
there they'll choose to be baptized um
you know kind of going under the waters
and the symbol of you know a new life in
Christ and such and um this has happened
multiple times where someone will make
that decision and I'm like and they kind
of have this moment you know it's like
super cool like hooray and you know if
you've been here for baptism Sundays
it's always cool like it's there it's
usually towards the beginning of the
year we got the big old horse trough out
real fancy here at the table so we got
the horse trough you know and everyone's
like celebrating like yeah you know and
they come out the waters and they're
just like glowing and we have pictures
and it's so cool. Um and then I never
see them
again. It's like fascinating. Like this
is what caught me off guard as a pastor
because it wasn't like this person
visited one time and then they're like I
want to be baptized. We're like oh okay,
you know, and then they disappeared. I
was like well that wouldn't be shocking
but someone was like involved for years
and it's like I'm going to be baptized.
Goodbye everyone. You know and it's not
even like they necessarily went to a
different church or that's okay.
Sometimes people feel called a different
place. No, I kind of checked in on them
and no, they're not going anywhere. Just
kind of gone. And I've kind of reflected
on this and I wonder if some of it is
the theme we're hitting on tonight. Like
in essence, right, they thought that it
was a uh it was a finish line, you know,
like they thought like I'm leaving Egypt
and entering the promised land.
Everything shall be changed, you know.
And what they didn't realize is they
were getting a baptism by water that was
initiating them into a baptism by
fire. Does that make sense? Like the
desert, they they thought they were
entering the promised land. They got the
desert and it completely shot their
wheels off. You know, so some of this is
my own kind of um you know, pastoral
care and such. I can do a better job of
communicating. Although I will say
literally in the baptism class I use
some of this language just so you know
this is a starting line not a you know
what I mean like I'm trying but I I
think in essence it's just something you
have to kind of go through you know um
you have to experience it the desert but
it's hard man the wilderness it's hard
and that catches people off
guard I think um the word discouragement
comes to
The desert can be really
discouraging, you know. It's almost like
you go through life really hoping like
if I'm lucky it'll be easy, you know,
and it just doesn't ever work that way,
you know? I mean, it's sort of
disappointing like I just really hoped
this would be easier.
And although maybe on the other hand, I
do hope for some of us it can be
encouraging because you might have be
thinking like, I thought I was supposed
to be in the promised land of the
Christian life, you know, and here I am
in the desert and I just wonder if like,
you know, God's left me or
something. But that's not the case. This
is the work of God in Christ. It's
actually God's grace to us that we don't
go from Egypt to the promised land. uh
because it's an inner transformation
that has to happen, right? It's an inner
healing. So what does this desert look
like? It looks like in Nichi's words, a
long obedience in the same
direction. It's the it's the path of
sanctification to use the language of
the book of Romans. It looks like it
looks like a lot of things. It looks
like u going to church week after week
and wondering is this even
working? Anyone ever thought that? Don't
raise your hand. Don't raise your hand.
I'm just joking. Um I have.
you know, like for me, for other like is
this work? What are we doing? You know,
or it's like uh it's like going to a
small group and here we call them
meetups. And at first it's like, you
know, it's like the honeymoon period, so
to speak. It's just, oh, everyone's so
great. They're so cool. They're so this
is awesome. I love have community and
friendships and and it's like after a
year you're like, well, these people
aren't as mature as I hoped they would
be. Yeah. And of course, what are they
thinking? You're not as mature as they
hoped you would be. You
know, that's kind of the nature of it.
It's thinking you found a community of
saints and realizing it's the old
phrase, it's a hospital of sinners. You
know, it's offending people and being
offended by them and learning to
apologize and forgive and like work out
the nitty-gritty of relationships. Of
course, it's not just church context.
It's it's family life. I mean, marital
life, the desert, relationship life, the
desert, family, extended family, those
ripple effects. Um, the challenges of
the desert. It's really, really hard.
But what happens? God uses our daily
rhythms and routines to reveal things to
us. We become more aware of our
stupidities and
immaturities. It knocks off our hard
edges. You might say the the desert is
is like a it's like a rock tumbler of
our life. And when engaged with
awareness, it eventually
smooths and reveals the presence of
Christ within. But it's difficult and
uncomfortable. And that's why we're
really tempted to run back to Egypt,
whatever that looks like for each of
each of us, it's different, you know,
back to old sort of unconscious ways of
being that are real comfortable but we
know are dysfunctional and unhelpful.
um back to addictions and old
patterns, back to old even friends
who maybe
um tell us not so much the truth but
what we want to hear, you
know. So all this this kind of begs the
question, you know, like how can we
endure, you know, h how do we make it
through the desert? Well, that leads us
to phase three, finding the provision.
Isaiah writes, "Forget the former
things. Do not dwell on the past."
Right? That's Egypt. Don't dwell on it.
See, I'm doing a new thing. Now, it
springs up. Do you not perceive it? I am
making a way in the wilderness for you.
Streams in the wasteland. The wild
animals, they honor me. the jackals, the
owls, because I provide water in the
wilderness and streams in the wasteland
to give drink to my people, my chosen,
the people I formed for myself that they
may proclaim my praise. Church, hear
this. Know God is making a way in the
wilderness for
you. A way for you, for your family, for
your friends, for our entire church
community. And not just a path away, but
there's going to be
streams. There's streams. There's times
of refreshment, places of renewal,
seasons of
healing. The author Marilyn Robinson in
her novel Gilead discusses a a different
biblical passage, but it has the same
like desert wilderness theme. She
writes, "The story of Hagar and Ishmael
says that it is not only the father of a
child who cares for its life, who
protects its mother and it says that
even if the mother can't find a way to
provide for it or herself, provision
will be made." At that level, it is a
story full of
comfort. That is how life
goes. We send our children into the
wilderness.
Some of them on the day they are born it
seems for all the help we can give them.
Some of them seem to be a kind of
wilderness unto
themselves. But there must be angels
there too and springs of water. Even
that wilderness, the very habitation of
jackals is the
Lord's. This is why Isaiah asked, "Do
you not perceive it?
Do you not have the eyes to see the
glory, the beauty around
you? Do you not see the grace of God in
your life to the people to your left and
to your right? Can you not perceive it?
Have you not been graced with a song of
birds, the night
sky, a meal with
friends, the deep nourishing silence of
prayer, the joy of receiving
communion? Have not each and every one
of us been graced by streams in the
desert, a path through the wilderness?
So, I know I know right now it's
hard. It's
hard for many of us. It's a hard season.
And that's why it's all the more
urgent that we nourish ourselves with
the streams, with the people, with the
places, with the experiences, with the
the authors, the films, the the
practices, the music, the arts, the
church community, the sacraments, the
spiritual exercises, anything.
Everything Christ has graced you with.
Soak it up. take it in and become that
stream, that path for others. Because
you see, our community, we're looking to
you to perceive
it so that we all might leave Egypt,
enter the desert, and eventually find
our way to the promised land together.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit. Amen.
So on the night that Jesus was betrayed,
he had one final meal with his
disciples. And at that meal, he held up
a loaf of bread and then he and he said,
"Take and eat. This is my body and it's
broken for you." And he held up a cup of
and he said, "Take it and drink. This is
my blood. It's shed for you. Whenever
you eat this bread, whenever you drink
this cup, remember
me. So as we come forward, let it be the
grace of God. Let let it be a stream for
you. Let it be something lifegiving.
This this symbol, this this connection
uh to to God. So the way that we'll go
about taking communion tonight is uh
we'll just go rowby row starting here at
the front and then we'll just work our
way backwards. We'll form one line right
here in the middle. We practice uh
what's called an open table. Meaning if
you're here tonight and you'd like to
participate, then you are free to do
that regardless of your exact, you know,
beliefs or something. Um if you
something in you wants to connect with
Christ in this way, then you're free to
do that. Having said that, there's also
no pressure. If you're not in a place
you want to do that, that's fine, too.
Uh you should know the red is wine, the
white is grape juice. And then finally,
you can just partake whenever and
however you'd like. Some folks like to
come and kneel here at the front. Others
like to partake immediately. others will
return to their seats and kind of
prayerfully take it there. However you
want to do that is fine. No one will
lead you through the exact moment of
partaking. This is the
table not of the
church but of the
Lord. And it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more. So come, come you who have
much faith and you who have little. You
who have been here often and you who
have not been here long. You who have
tried to follow and you who have failed,
come. Come. Because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you. And it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
Hey, hey,
hey. Heat. Hey. Hey. Hey.
[Music]
Hey. Hey.
Hey. Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Are you playing here right now? No.
All right.
So, testing testing. Is this on? 1 2 3.
Hello. Hello.
[Music]
Okay. So, can yay. Okay. It's on. We're
going to end today with um way maker.
We're going to end it with a really good
song and I just wanted to open up by
kind of refreshing what um Pastor Brett
was talking about how we really are all
in our own desert. Some of us may be in
Egypt. Some of us may be in a promised
land. Some of us may be at a stream. Um
and I think a lot of us in our own
personal lives are looking at the path
ahead of us and we're saying, "God,
like it's going to be really
interesting. And I don't know how you're
going to do it, but you know, when
you're in that moment, when I'm in that
moment, when we're all in that moment,
just remember God's track
record. Hey, remember God's track
record. And you're here, you're sitting
in this room. You've made it thus far.
Bad things have happened to us, but God
made a way to make it work out. So, just
go into that truth with this song and
knowing that God does make a way and
it's going to be okay.
Even when you're scared, God makes a way
for us even when we're scared. So, just
open yourself up to that truth tonight.
And I hope that these words bless
[Music]
you. You are
here moving in our
midst. I worship
you. I worship you.
You are
here working in this
place. I worship
you. I worship
you cuz you are way maker, miracle
worker, promise keeper, light in the
darkness. My God, that is who you are.
You are way maker, miracle worker,
promise keeper, light in my darkness. My
God, that is who you
are. You are
here touching every
heart. I worship
you. I worship you.
You are
here healing every
heart. I worship
you. I worship
you. You are
here turning lives
around. I worship
you. I worship
you. You are here.
and every
heart. I worship
you. I worship
you cuz you are way maker, miracle
worker, promise keeper, light in my
darkness. My God, that is who you are.
You are way maker, miracle worker,
promise keeper, light in my darkness. My
God, that is who you
are. That is who you
are. That is who you are.
That is who you
are. That is who you
are. Even when I don't see it, you're
working. Even when I don't feel it,
you're working. You never stop. You
never stop working. You never stop. You
never stop working. Even when I don't
see it, you're working. Even when I
don't feel it, you're working. You never
stop. You never stop working. You never
stop. You never stop working. Even when
I don't see it, you're working. Even
when I don't feel it, you're working.
Never stop. Never stop working. You
never stop. You never
stop. Even when I don't see it, you're
working. Even when I don't feel it,
you're working. You never stop. You
never stop working. You never stop. Cuz
you are way maker, miracle worker,
promise keeper, light in my darkness. My
God. That is who you
are. You are way maker, miracle worker,
promise keeper, light in my darkness. My
God, that is who you are.
That is who you
are. That is who you
are. That is who you are.
Way maker, miracle worker, promise
keeper, light in my darkness. My God,
that is who you are. Just the voices you
are. Way maker, miracle worker, promise
keep, light in my darkness. My God, that
is who you are.
[Music]
Thank you so much for being here with us
this evening. Um if you're new, we'd
love for you to fill out um a card
that's on the table out there or you can
scan the QR code um just to say thanks
for being here and answer any questions
you might have about our community. We
could all use more relational support
and spiritual connection. And the way we
do that at the table is through meetups.
Um, if you're not yet part of a meetup,
you can scan the QR code to find one
that works for you. Generosity is a key
aspect of a life of adoration and
worship. If the table is your church
home, then we invite you to scan the QR
code and give financially or visit the
tabletx.org. Um, and now I'm going to
send you into your week with a blessing.
You can hold out your hands in a posture
to receive or just open your heart to
these words.
You are a child of
God. You are a child of
God. This is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day. So, as you
go into your week ahead with its yet to
be determined highs and lows and
everything in between, go filled with
the assurance that you are loved.
You are
worthy and you are
accepted just as you
are. And go filled with God's Holy
Spirit and the desire to extend these
same gifts of grace and unconditional
love to everyone you come into contact
with. Be blessed and we'll see you next
Sunday or at Hackerise.
[Music]
My God, that is who you are.